law enforcement warded a massive jail
escape plot in Tennessee a man was
arrested for allegedly hiding a
stockpile of weapons inside an unopened
detention center Omar Villafranca is
outside the facility in Nashville Omar
how did police catch him well good
morning investigators say it was
surveillance video where they saw Alex
Friedman stealing keys from a detention
center control room and further
investigation found that there was a
much bigger plan in progress now
Friedman was arrested in January on
charges including attempted burglary and
evidence tampering
once he had access Friedman allegedly
planted loaded guns ammunition and
security equipment around the building
investigators are still searching for
three other men believed to have helped
Friedman with the escape plot let me be
very clear
he has also put every inmate every
visitor in our entire community in
jeopardy
in 1991 Friedman was convicted on
multiple charges including assault with
intent to murder and he ended up serving
10 years in prison he had since turned
his life around and was even featured in
the documentary as a criminal justice
reform advocate now that detention
center was scheduled to open in April
but that is now obviously delayed
because law enforcement has to sweep
that and see if there are any more
weapons inside tony omar thank you very
much